foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
Precision oncology Alliance a vision to
the Future
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual cancer research and immuno
oncology week
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can also participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the
asking question box and click submit
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window on the
sidebar to the left of the presentation
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
I now present today's speaker Dr Shadi
Navan chairman and precision oncology
Alliance at Karis life sciences and
Adjunct professor at the University of
South Carolina
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
Dr naban you may now begin your
presentation
well thanks everyone I'm going really to
talk today about large research networks
and how this can help the development
and evolution of frankly clinical
research in the world of precision and
ecology and I'm going to use the Keras
Precision oncology Alliance platform
as a conduit to explain that
now in in doing so it is probably
important to to start by recognizing
that
the importance of providing broad
molecular profiling and sequencing for
patients who are diagnosed with cancer
this obviously helps scaling up the
research operations by looking at
mutations and molecular abnormalities
that could be missed or could not be
identified or detected when you do again
a narrow platform for sequencing
at Karis what we are doing is we're
doing whole exome whole transcriptome
sequencing on every tissue that we
receive in the lab this is important
because it does provide us and provide
along with providers with more molecular
information than just what is clinically
needed today
it provides information to scale up
research to help with potential projects
that Aid in drug Discovery and also we
know that many mutations and many
genomic aberrations that are clinically
relevant today
they were not clinically relevant before
that's really how research occurs and
that's how it evolves look KRS is a
perfect example KRS g12c it was not
something that I learned about when I
was in training and now there are
targets for this particular oncogene and
many have argued previously that it was
an oncogene that you could not drug
so clearly having this broad sequencing
could help from a research perspective
so I want to emphasize this is partly of
why this is being done the whole exome
whole transcriptome sequencing on all of
the tissue that we receive
and from a research perspective because
we actually
sequence many patients every single day
at Keras we provide the raw data to the
institutions and to the investigators
that sequence their patients with us
this is also important for the research
operation on a local level there are
many research projects that could occur
and might be needed on a local level on
a Healthcare System level on a network
level and such research operation
requires the availability of the raw
data that are linked with clinical
information as well as outcomes and we
do that so from a research perspective
we think about that on a local level and
we think of that on a broader level as
well so I want to make sure there's a
clear understanding of the rationale of
why there's a data return commitment on
the raw level to all of the providers
and the institutions that sequence with
with us
and when it when when it comes to the um
well I I think I mentioned I mentioned
that the feed of that data also could
return daily weekly monthly this is
something that usually we discuss and
agree upon with the institution that
sequences with with us
now when it comes to the clinical
information and what we need clinically
as well on the research front it is very
important to have a pipeline that is
really commensurate with the progress of
the molecular Revolution how I call it
and liquid profiling is something that
is coming upon us it is something that
we are looking and exploring and we are
working on diligently it is starting to
become available over the next few
months and again our liquid profiling is
going to allow us to have RNA and DNA
from the blood this is very important
because you know as you know if you
don't do the RNA seek you could miss
certain fusions that are very important
on clinical grounds for some tumors and
this is really why we are working on the
liquid profiling for that to perfect
that technology to assure that nothing
gets missed from a patient perspective
this is very critical because patients
care as well what the patients will
receive dependent on that
but when it comes to research if I want
to step back because again what I want
to really cover today
is how we are leveraging the networks
and the research collaboration to
advance Precision oncology research and
to do that we need obviously data
and data is power when it comes to the
research capabilities and it goes
without saying that doing research today
for for patients with cancer requires
understanding the molecular
underpinnings of tumors
as well as the clinical information and
more importantly the outcomes and really
knowing that on a longitudinal patient
journey is very critical to to allow us
to start asking research questions that
are very critical and have answers to
these questions
so we have invested a lot uh into our
data platform and currently what we have
is over 400 000 molecularly profiled
patients with cares you see that on the
right hand side of the slide and you see
the progression of the data from 2020 a
couple of years back when we had 225 000
to today when there are over four
hundred thousand but what is also unique
is the fact that we have over a quarter
million of these patients currently 275
000 that we have outcomes data linked to
that molecular information that is
really the Holy Grail trying to
understand the molecular underpinnings
of the tumor and then with time how does
this really relate to outcomes such as
overall Survival how does this relate to
the treatments that the patients receive
in the real world and and and What
treatments they receive at progression
at relapse second line third line
so having that molecular data is
critical and not only that because we
have been doing as I told you whole
exome and whole transcriptome sequencing
for several years currently we stand at
182 000 whole transcriptome data with
outcomes 129
000 whole exome with outcomes it goes
without saying this is large database
has the molecular information has the
outcomes on top of it and that molecular
information is certainly critical to
scale the research operation that data
comes from patients and providers that
are sequencing patients for clinical
indication to decide on best clinical
care
so where does the network fit in where
does the network fit in and how do we
really build a large Network
we build that by creating a
collaboration between our scientific
platform our data progress and create
something we called at Keras the
Precision oncology Alliance the Keras
Precision oncology Alliance is this
collaborative Network that takes the
data progress that we have takes the
scientific platform that we have and
creates a network that continues to grow
and expand so we can take advantage of
that exhaustive data set that continuing
data set to grow that data set does not
stay stagnant in fact it continues to
grow so that's really what we what is
important so we had to create a network
that leversed that data set but that
Network had to be large enough because
we want to be able to advance precision
and college research
so the Precision oncology Alliance was
born to be able to take advantage of all
of that
what is the vision of the Precision
oncology Alliance as a large Network
the Precision oncology Alliance that we
have of Karis is the leading cancer
research Enterprise in the world this is
really the vision of this in order to
advance and improve on the outcomes of
patients with cancer in order to
optimize the way we take care of
patients we need to take that data and
put it to use
research-wise so I'll read this verbatim
the care is precision oncology Alliance
vision is to be the leading cancer
research Enterprise in the world
exclusively focused on Precision
oncology to optimize clinical care and
outcomes of patients with cancer
again this is cannot be done without
larger Network that takes advantage of
the data set so this is how we can
leverage the capabilities across various
institutions and leveraging the
collaboration so where we stand right
now we are at 70 it's not even 69 now
it's 70 sites from across the country
these sites have access to this data set
that I just told you about these sites
have access to the research capabilities
and their and the ability to start
asking and Mining the data and asking
questions
amongst these institutions that are part
of the Precision oncology Alliance is as
an example the National Cancer Institute
or and 30 and 30 NCI comprehensive
designated Cancer Centers the goal again
is let's access this data set
let's start asking questions let's make
sure these questions that we are asking
are pragmatic they are relevant to
Patient Care they are important to
advance how we take care of patients and
hopefully the output of that research
can lead to improvements in the outcomes
in order to have any network by the way
any large Network out there you need to
have a proper governance you need to
have a proper way and a platform to
govern the relationships and to govern
the operations and the processes that
you really conduct in that Network I
would say for anyone who is looking at
establishing or growing a network it is
important to have that and to Think
Through the governance process and we
did that exactly at the Precision
oncology Alliance so from a governance
perspective we have an executive
committee that you see on the slide the
executive committee is currently
composed of 10 faculty members from
across the Precision and college
Alliance along with myself and we think
about what can what do we need to do
strategically operationally to assure
that what we actually bring to alliance
members is commensurate with their
expectations of what we actually are
expected to do on a research front
but you know that there's significant
sub-specialization in the world of
oncology and in order for us to take
advantage of the data set that we have
and to improve the research operation we
need to divide the alliance into working
groups and these working groups are
usually focused on different tumors
so you see here we have 18 tumor Types
on this slide it's self-explanatory
because every disease group is focused
on the particular area of research
interest
usually these disease groups meet at a
particular Cadence and they discuss
research ideas they discuss new projects
they discuss Publications as you could
see here we have a pathology disease
group we have a Pediatrics Aya disease
group you know that there are
significant interest in the Pediatrics
and adolescents and young adults type of
tumors and it is really interesting to
try to look at the molecular profile
that might be different based on age
groups we also started looking at
radiomics and created a radiation
oncology disease group the radiation
oncology disease group is focused on
correlating radiotherapy with biomarkers
and chemotherapy and trying to
understand maybe what drives responses
and changes of therapy on the molecular
level in patients who receive radiation
therapy
furthermore I think it is very critical
to understand
that asking disparities questions is
hopefully going to lead to better equity
in healthcare and we know that patients
who are enrolled in clinical trials
don't always represent patients in the
real world demographics and age-wise and
socioeconomic status because of this we
feel that we within the Precision
oncology Alliance confines we're able to
really start looking at disparities in
outcomes also disparities on the genomic
level various disparities and by asking
questions related to that we can start
creating strategies that can help reach
Equity towards the end and making sure
that all patients are receiving the
proper therapies but it is critical to
understand the differences on the
genomic level between various age groups
between men women between various races
and ethnicities and also hopefully with
time understanding social determinants
of health and how can we overcome some
of these inequities moving forward
it is further important to actually as
you build a network and you look at
various networks of collaboration think
of the fellows in trainings all
oncologists at some point were fellows
and I think identifying opportunities to
Mentor fellows Within These networks is
very critical identifying opportunities
to provide research ideas to the fellows
is also very important so this is really
critical
when it comes to looking at Network
expansions
now when I think about what the
objectives of creating the Keras
Precision oncology Alliance I like to
put into these five buckets but as you
think about creating various networks if
you're listening to this you know think
about the objectives why is the network
being created what are what are you
trying to accomplish the only way to
know whether you are successful is by
identifying milestones and trying to
understand what's going to get you from
point A to point B and having frequent
checks whether the Milestones that
you're trying to achieve to get you from
point A to point B are being fulfilled
from a Keras Precision oncology Alliance
objectives it is trying to identify uh
what how best to take care of patients
with cancer from a Precision oncology
perspective because today in 2022 when
you take care of patients with cancer
you must know the molecular underpinning
of the tumor otherwise you cannot really
provide the best care
education and mentoring is an important
objective of the carers Precision
oncology Alliance also clinical trials
research Publications helping data
abstraction helping combinations
you know when you know I'll give you an
example for the Precision oncology
patient care what does that mean it
means that we can actually identify
certain patterns
that might help in patient care this is
an example of something that the
Precision oncology Alliance GI group
identified as an important question so
for example again that question may be
may not be relevant in 10 years from now
but today it is still relevant patients
with metastatic colorectal cancer
receiving the first line for the most
part either for Theory or fall fox in
first line metastatic disease commonly
in combination with bevacizumab as a
biological agent and leveraging the data
set that I showed you we were able to
identify basically a genomic profile
that really tells the patient and the
physician which sequence is better
should we start with fall Fox first or
with full Theory first usually patients
with metastatic colorectal cancer
receive both combinations in sequence
but it's never really clear which is the
better sequence a followed by b or B
followed by a so so identifying a
genomic signature that tells you the
better sequence definitely helps
patients and it is something that we
were able to identify leveraging the
collaboration with the Precision
oncology alliance members and
subsequently that paper was published in
clinical cancer research over a year ago
using that model
signatures that might actually help
Drive patient care it is really
important when you look from a network
perspective
to really look at the type of research
questions and how pragmatic they are how
important they are so we identify
usually questions that have direct
relevance to the way patients are being
poor cared for and this is just a simple
example of various signatures again this
is not an inclusive list but certainly
it is very important to do that I talked
to you about mentoring right I talked to
you about mentoring we talked a little
bit about the uh how we actually drive
patient care through the Precision and
college research and you remember we
also talked about the importance of
Publications
and research output and and and you know
the collaborative effort having that
many institutions that many
investigators putting all of our heads
together will lead to improved output
when it comes to Publications and when
it comes to uh output so you will see
here as an example in 2022 so far we've
had 14 probably going close to 20
frankly but at least for now I'll put in
the 14 and we've had 75 abstracts or
posters so far and if you look at just a
few months ago when we had the American
Society of clinical oncology meeting in
Chicago the Precision oncology Alliance
produced and published 45 abstract that
were peer-reviewed including two merit
awards and three accepted poster
discussions so that is really important
because again being able to Foster and
bring a lot of research outputs out
there is very critical and helps to
improve of patient care at the European
Society of medical oncology meeting
we've had nine poster presentations
including a mini oral session that was
presented on small cell lung cancer
extra pulmonary small cell carcinoma
again research Publications should be
part of the large Network goals that
we're trying to accomplish
but also it's really important to things
to think proactively and start thinking
about how can the network in addition to
leveraging the data profile and the data
set that we have can how can we actually
improve on identifying
prospective Interventional type of
studies that might change shape or alter
patient care and and what we have done
through the Keras Precision ecology
Alliance is to help and Aid where we can
with investigator initiated studies we
are in the process of launching various
sponsor studies where we can leverage
our tissue platform our liquid platform
to answer questions that are very
critical to Patient Care and also we are
in the process of working with
Cooperative groups to hopefully identify
trials that are very important to
patient care but how can we really
answer some of the questions in these
trials
on the molecular level so again thinking
from a collaborative perspective none of
these could happen none of these could
happen without large collaborative
Network formation that has proper
governance proper guidance and most
importantly proper goals so we've talked
about patient care we've talked about
research Publications we've talked about
education and mentorship and data
abstraction how about clinical trials
this was the fifth objective that I told
you about
and it is very important to think about
clinical trials I'll step back I already
told you that clinical trials or
patients that are enrolled in clinical
trials don't always represent
patients that are being seen in the real
world whether it is from demographics
perspective whether it is from having
fewer comorbidities in the clinical
trial setting compared to real world
where it is having better socioeconomics
tests or even psychosocial support to
get into a clinical trial you need to be
able to have transportation to get to
the actual Center that has the trial
so you must be able to have the proper
support so we wanted to overcome that
barrier and we wanted to create a system
where there's possibility of the trials
going to the patient as opposed to the
patient coming to the trial and in doing
so we have we have the right in time
approach for clinical trials we have
several studies that are actually uh
available to larger Network sites that
may not be at the main center of the
academic center
where these trials open enroll and start
accruing at the time of molecular
abnormality detection
so this is very critical because you
know that patients are not going to be
able to get in a taxi or a bus or a
train and go to where the trial is in
fact there has been many resource
studies market research studies that
suggested the majority of patients don't
want to drive more than 25 months in
radius understandably so and because of
that there's hindrance on enrolling
patients in clinical trials but if a
patient can enroll in a clinical trial
it is appropriate to him or her without
having the burden of travel and
transportation
this will certainly help so I want to
make sure there's good understanding
that this is part of the objectives of
the Precision oncology Alliance and
we're hopefully able to accomplish that
now when it comes to being able to
provide the scientific support it is
really important as you build the
network to start looking at you know you
need an infrastructure to provide
scientific leadership and support
because again the network is growing now
we have 70 sites we may have 75 sites by
the end of 2022 as the network grows
providing the scientific support for
network members institutions and faculty
is very critical and we cannot do that
without having scientists across the
country who are providing that support
to various Network institutions but what
is really important is that these
scientists who are present across the
country can provide help with education
and about a report you know if sometimes
you talk to a to oncologist and they
will say the biggest headache is when I
get 30 page report about the molecular
profiling of a patient so having a
resource somebody available to you that
can actually answer questions pertaining
to that report is very critical because
it's going to help in driving patient
care
but also could be educating the staff
educating the fellows educating advanced
practice providers giving lectures
internally all of this is very important
in addition to that discussing research
idea you're a member of the network and
you have an idea research idea you'd
like to bring It Forward you can have a
scientist to start discussing this with
and go back and forth before that idea
is submitted formally to for for us or
to the network members for consideration
and also really looking at molecular
tumor boards many institutions across
the country has formed or in the process
of forming molecular tumor boards these
molecular tumor boards they meet at
various cadences at these institutions
depending frankly on how busy the
institution is but the molecular tumor
boards provide insights into a molecular
underpinning of a particular patient but
then what type of therapeutic
recommendations the tumor board usually
recommends and these scientists at the
Keras Life Sciences Provide support to
the molecular tumor board what's also
important is in The Same Spirit we
created the Keras molecular tumor board
because there are some smaller
institutions or smaller practices that
they may be faced with certain uh
scenarios or cases that they struggle
with in terms of how they're going to
manage that clinically how they're going
to manage that uh um in taking care of
patients so having a resource a
molecular tumor board they can send the
case to the Keras molecular tumor board
and say Hey you know we have this case
it is very challenging it is very
difficult
could you help in providing some ideas
into how patients are going to
um you know undergo uh therapy and what
type of therapy can we actually uh make
that happen so I think this is really
very helpful for the resources where
these resources are not always available
um and then you know it's really
important to create a vehicle for
communication in any large Network
having that sense of community is very
critical having the sense of belonging
whether you are a member of the whether
you are a member investigator as part of
the alliance or you are a member
institution as part of the alliance
having that sense of community is very
critical so we created the Keras
Precision ecology Alliance communication
platform and within that we have a
newsletter that is currently quarterly I
think we can change that with more
resources to maybe monthly or every six
weeks usually we highlight some of the
activities at Precision oncology
Alliance sites we can provide updates on
the pipeline what's actually happening
what is happening for Publications
abstracts new meetings upcoming meetings
all of these are very important and
again create a sense of community
usually I meet with an investigator from
the Precision oncology Alliance and make
sure that I'm actually you know
highlight his or her research activities
and really provide that in a video
format or an interview format to
everybody who is in the alliance a
podcast there are many folks who like to
listen to podcasts when they're driving
we create the Keras molecular Minute
Podcast this is a podcast that just
allows you to listen to a particular
um again topic that is on the
intersection of clinical medicine or
clinical decision making and precision
oncology and you know we're working on
videos and video podcasts are very short
clip and again also the web website
having a website for the actual Network
that is very easy to access very easy to
navigate very easy to communicate is
very critical we are in a digital world
and having that available on the network
level is extremely important to make
sure you're positioned in a way that's
really Foster the collab operative
efforts because the goal of this you
want to create a platform to scale up
collaboration by scaling up the
collaboration everyone stands to benefit
but the ultimate stakeholder in the
entire collaboration here is frankly the
patient and I've always said we are
either current patients future patients
or past patients so in any forming of
any collaborative Network in anything
that we're trying to accomplish we need
to create a format that's going to
Foster this because ultimately the
individual that is going to benefit from
this is the patient that we are caring
for so again the communication platform
is very critical and we've created that
on a network level and as you could see
here by doing this you create a large
Network that continues to expand create
a collaboration create a community and
that Community leverage the data the
platform the science but most
importantly the brain power the brain
power hour of people who are taking care
of patients day in and day out to make
it happen I hope this really helped in
explaining how we went around uh be at
Karis in creating this large Network
called the Keras Precision oncology
Alliance I hope that you agree that the
POA or the Precision oncology Alliance
is a very good platform that is helping
patients investigators institutions and
everyone to benefit the patient I really
appreciate you listening to me and
taking the time of your schedule and I'm
happy to take any questions at this
point thank you
thank you Dr naban for your time today
and your important research before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today questions submitted
today and during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until October 6 2024. lab
rutual or you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any one of
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye